e
[Musique]
chaque soir depuis noël trinidad résonne
du son des bidons de pétrole
à la tombée du jour la rue appartient au
steel band la musique envahit porthos
penh la capitale
ici on ne vit plus qu'à l'heure du
carnaval
côté court aussi on s'affaire les
costumes doivent être prêt demain tous
les quinze jours avant le carnaval des
grands les enfants ouvrent le bal un an
de patience et de travail pour les
mamans toute la journée à rire et à
danser pour les enfants n'oublient pas
quand le vent va commencer à te gêne et
tu tournes jusqu'à ce que tu te sens tu
à l'aise fait en sorte de décider en
t'amusant le plus possible devant les
jeunes comme ça tu auras le maximum de
points gagnés quand ma fille m'a demandé
de dessiner elle avait 4 ans et je n'ai
vraiment pas pu lui refuser ça fait
partie de notre culture si petits qu'ils
soient les enfants jours c'est quelque
chose qu'on a dans le sang et à partir
du moment où on entend la musique du
carnaval le calypso et soca c'est un
mouvement naturel
mind et yang et cela regarde et il
commence à dire si les planchers
[Musique]
ils ont la musique en eux ils continuent
et l'énergie coule à flots jusqu'à la
fin personne n'est fatigué jusqu'à ce
que ce soit fini
et alors on bien c'était épuisant
le dernier mouvement et on se laisse
tomber jusqu'à l'année prochaine
[Musique]
kelly
cannes film rabbit san fernando dans le
sud de l'île musicien compositeur
arrangeur c'est un passionné à 30 ans il
dirige cinq steel band différents la
musique il la vit ça fait vraiment
partie de trinidad c'est l'instrument
national mais c'est un des meilleurs
moments pour tous les trinidadiens c'est
le moment du carnaval
il y a beaucoup de spectacles de calypso
il ya beaucoup de compétitions de
steelband il ya plein de choses à ce
moment de l'année
tout le monde est simplement heureux
tout le pays parce qu'il ya plein
d'endroits où aller il ya des calypsos
défaite c'est vraiment un des meilleurs
moments à trinidad
[Musique]
le chanteur de calypso sait saisir
l'instant sur le vif avec humour ses
paroles improvise sur les événements de
la vie de tous les jours petits ou
grands le calypso n'y est en quelque
sorte un commentateur politique ou
sociale chaque mardi kane film or seront
au collège de san fernando un moment
privilégié une heure par semaine
il donne le goût de la musique aux
jeunes lycéens
ce
[Musique]
oh
ce sont les élèves de l'école et tout le
monde ici apprend à jouer du steel band
et quand ils apprennent à jouer il ne
traîne pas gross et sa voix si le solo
du festival de l'école c'était quand en
novembre c'est ça c'est ça en novembre
c'est un très bon joueur tu joues un peu
pour eux fait juste deux mesures quelle
est votre impression quand vous
enseignez à l'échelle et dave j'enseigne
aux jeunes je vois que la culture ne
meurt pas je crois ce que quand
j'abandonnerai les enfants que vous
venez de voir ce seront eux qui
continueront et une fois que vous avez
des enfants qui aiment cette musique
c'est un rêve pour moi de voir que la
musique va survivre
[Musique]
oh
prendre le temps de vivre dans la
caraïbe c'est important allison ron
danseuses et chanteuses de calypso
prépare comme tous ici le carnaval mais
la musique prend toujours le dessus
il n'y a jamais de problème la trinidad
je crois qu'en général dans les caraïbes
tout le monde dit pas de problème
et vous savez c'est beaucoup plus lente
dans les grands pays
probablement à cause du soleil tout le
monde marche langoureusement et en
général les trinidadiens prennent
plaisir à faire tout ce qu'ils font dans
une semaine allison sera une des reines
du carnaval
personne encore n'a pu voir son costume
pas même elle c'est un secret
oui
[Applaudissements]
trois missions en haïti
à
oh
ce soir là le style bonne de ton fils
mort à gagner la compétition la semaine
prochaine ils seront les challengers du
carnaval de trinidad
[Musique]
non